we are taking calls via Discord
davidpackman.com Discord just a reminder
if you want to get on your nickname uh
must be your name and where you're
calling from or where you're calling
from and your name you know just names
alone or nicknames or sort stuff like
that is not likely to get you on let's
go to Rodney from St Louis Rodney from
St Louis welcome to the program
hey David can you hear me yes I can
okay great uh first of all I want to say
congratulations on last week or week and
a half ago when you had the right wing
attacking you and uh your audience was
able to Rally we made it we made it
Rodney I appreciate that
yeah it was amazing just got me thinking
that uh obviously the number one thing
that we all run into on every single
issue is the money-powered interest yes
and every single time the media doesn't
ever cover it and it's not really
covered that much even on Independent
Media but I would think if maybe I don't
know if you and like Sam and Jack or tyt
and others on the left ever get together
and like try to like use your audiences
to strategically get the word out or
even acknowledge that the left media is
even existing yeah you know we really
don't and we should the last time I saw
Jenkins Sam was like in the same place I
saw Sam more recently but the last time
the three of us were in the same place
was at a conference in Vegas like right
before the pandemic and I'll be honest
this this particular issue did not come
up it was really kind of a social thing
we went to dinner but I actually do
think you know one of the things I've
talked about before and I think you're
kind of getting at this Rodney is that
when it come to funding Independent
Media and creating this sort of like
under
belly sounds negative but in a sense
it's an underbelly it's a layer we might
call it of a media to really try to get
young people to come to our side right
when they leave College
the right funds that to an insane degree
I mean I I recently heard I don't know
if this is true that Turning Point USA
raised like 40 million dollars or
something like that and the right has
way more of these right-wing think tanks
whether when you join you're much better
paid than if you're on the left then you
join like whatever the left-wing
equivalent would be
so I actually think there would be a lot
of value it doesn't have to be you know
me along with Jenkins Sam but somebody
and I'm willing to be a part of it and
obviously Jenkins Sam would be great
people to have involved as well we need
to just make really clear like listen to
some degree like there's not actually a
mystery about what's going on here we're
winning on so many of the issues when
you ask people to review on abortion the
review on gay marriage The View on using
taxes all these different things it's
like it's very clear the left is winning
on the issues but we simply aren't doing
what we need to do in terms of funding
the messaging and the right crushes us
on this and for all the talk about
George Soros George Soros has never
funded me or any of the people you
mentioned and and it is something where
if the left is ghosting you guys they're
ghosting a hundred percent yeah like I
mean 100 when's the last time you've
seen AOC or Bernie talk about David
packman or tyt or the majority report
that 100 like that needs to happen 100
this spark has to happen yeah and I
think we need to have more advocates in
Congress address and and we do have some
you know rocon is a big Advocate and I
think to some degree like Eric swalwell
then I can certainly name people but
Europe this is a huge systemic problem
it's bigger than me Jenkins Sam but to
the extent I can be a part of solving it
I'm glad to be
yeah you guys are just in my wheelhouse
yeah you know I agree with 99 of what
you guys you know talk about and I love
it like you're going to do a great job
thanks so much Rodney great great call
and great topic
thank you all right there goes Rodney
let's take just a very quick break just
to let cooler heads prevail no I'm
kidding we just need a quick break if
you're still wanting to talk to me just
hold on because we're coming right back
to the phones after this